mach est avec toi ça y est je suis
arrivé en même temps benjamin et au
début toi tu manges tu dois faire qu'une
ou deux oui bah oui oui en fait c'est
vrai que j'ai au départ quand je suis
arrivé j'ai vu benjamin j'étais
tellement impressionné parce que
j'allais dans lost et touba oui c'était
quand même c'est une rock-star je le
connaissais de l'at elle ne connaissait
pas ça alors ça c'est un truc que j'ai
jamais eue ce qui vous avait
impressionné par ben oui enfin tout d'un
coup on dit tu vas peut-être faire une
émission télé de temps en temps avec
benjamin castaldi effectivement j'étais
très impressionné et est en fait était
pas qu'il ya un truc qui me lie à
benjamin parce qu'on est arrivés
ensemble c'était au moment où il y avait
aussi au cou et qui était venu un petit
peu oui c'est vrai et après on est sur
moi aussi et c'était c'était très
impressionnant parce qu'avec eux des
gens très très connus autour de moi donc
et puis après bon je vous ai vue est
effectivement déjà merci merci de
m'avoir fait confiance moi vous m'avez
appris ce métier j'apprends tous les
jours ça réussit même pas d'où vous
venez vous faites
comment je faisais venir chez mes
basques en fait un jour j'étais venu à
la radio à europe 1 pour parler dans mes
bouquins et vous aviez trouvé que
j'étais plutôt sympathique à l'époque et
vous
aucune
et comme c'était sérieux béatrice est
détenu par exactement par hasard et du
coup après je suis ni de temps en temps
et puis d'un pelage j'ai fait ça pendant
un an et après bon c'est plus vu et
après on va vous m'avez rappelé pour
éventuellement venir j'avais démarré la
radio avec moi je savais même pas mais
vous vous en souveniez par un bon c'est
juste un nom de radio les pin up avec
jean luc lemoine y avait il ya des
bigarrée les bellemare y avait à dire il
va dévaler c'était un court mais là
aussi ces vaccins commandés je l'avais
jean pierre foucault j'ai pas seulement
vous imaginez j'étais entre jean pierre
foucault et jean marie bigard c'est vrai
c'était tellement intimidant et aurait
été énorme avec jérôme commandeur aussi
avec dans un style adénomes gerosa
uniquement qu'à la fin c'est un casting
de fou avec des fous rire tous les jours
elle va pouvoir faire et calais sevriena
et vous après donc après attention à la
radio on faisait les missions et vous
moi je faisais munitions c'était énorme
et après vous partiez en folie comme une
sorte de marathonien tous ferté pmp des
incroyables rythme était complètement le
rythme le pire c'est à une année j'avais
fait virgin radio oui je faisais le
matin je sais dès 6h et 9h je faisais tu
es pmp et faisait la nouvelle star a
prêté pembe et le matin je me lève à
4h30 je me rappelle est en une année
j'avais pris huit ans
et comme je vous l ai toujours dit et
rien ne change dans ce que je dis moi je
vous trouve absolument extraordinaire
j'ai toujours dit que vous étiez pour
moi une rock star du paf lui la seule
rock star du paf vous êtes un truc salif
instinctif vous êtes hyper sensible vous
sentez les choses comme un buvard moi
vous me faites vous m'apprenez ce métier
là parce que je suis né à saint genèse
unis connaissez rien donc j'apprends je
progresse je chute je me relève voilà je
suis je suis en gestation grâce à vous
etc etc moi j'estime que j'ai énormément
de chance d'avoir cette liberté de
parler tous les soirs sur des sujets de
société qu'on maîtrise plus ou moins on
dit avec ton coeur et tout ça est
vraiment c'est un luxe absolu ouais je
sais bien que vous disais-je et parce
que il ya encore beaucoup de gens mais
voilà qui ont réagi jeudi
géraldine et moi on s'aime on s'adore
essayé de rouler le hic c'est qu'il n'y
a aucun sujet que je riais maintenant
les relations chaloupe à géraldine aron
l'adorent mais elle sera là tous les
jours avec nous et moi je vois là je me
régale et comme j'ai dis vraiment vous
faites tous aujourd'hui le succès tp ou
dit c'est moi mais aujourd'hui les
scores d'audience et le nombre de
personnes
et au delà des audiences nombre de
personnes qui nous regardent et qui nous
interpelle dans la rue et qui nous
disent le public qui vient nous voir ils
viennent vous voir aussi un joli nommé
l'achat d'accord avec delphine non non
non non tpm franchement c'est vous c'est
nous ont pas son nom non il est enlisé à
lundi c'est vous c'est nous mêmes salles
indispensable
j'arrive pas du tout c'est charles
pasqua dispensable c'est nivea crème
[Rires]
pas vraiment non et je vous jure est là
alors on agira d innovation oui encore
oui bonjour les pirates vous rendez pas
compte comme les gens sont attachés à la
famille y a pas que moi il fallait à la
famille et toute la famille sont
attachés à la famille même les nouveaux
cas rivaux clément ou delphine ils sont
attachés à benjamin à vous elle admet
nicolas nicolas aussi italienne à voile
ou le même gilles tu vois tout le monde
mais
je vous jure les gens premier dont il
parle projet de la rue